The Joe Rogan Experience wolves are
dominant intelligent calculating
Predators yeah that they eradicated from
the West for a reason yeah
Yeah man so I think he hit on a bunch of
things that would like bring me back to
my opinion on it and that's that
a lot of this stuff when you when so I
know they they've basically described
two different areas in Colorado where
they're going to put the two or the uh
the two first sets of transplants and
one of them is like right in where
you're not I mean
I rode that country with a horse like
all over the place in the circle of
where they're going to put those wolves
is right there so I know where they're
gonna put those you know one of the
spots I know the spot intimately I know
the wildlife there intimately how many
wolves are they gonna put in so my
understanding is off the bat the first
year and I and I I believe their goal is
by December of this year
um it's going to be like between 15 and
30 I believe is the first bunch and
they're going to have them in two
different two different spots but in
that you're in that Veil Veil quarter
Corridor you know up to the flat tops in
there uh you know so they're probably
gonna put 15 to 20 wolves in there the
thing the thing that you hit on Joe that
I think kind of forms my opinion is I
mean these areas when you go in a man
they seem so wild right like you know I
could the flat tops I could get on a
horse and I could ride for 15 15 hours
and not see a road you know or 10 hours
and not see a road and they seem so wild
even to me being there but I don't think
that people realize how much how much
humans have already affected that
landscape and how it doesn't matter like
the this myth that putting wolves back
in the land that landscape is going to
turn it back to some ecosystem that was
here you know 300 years ago I I I think
it's I think it's a figment of their
imagination man and and the reason I say
that is because
I've also spent a fair amount of time in
British Columbia that seemed so much
more wild to me and let me kind of like
give you context of why that is you know
you've have you ever been to Vail
Colorado no yeah okay oh I I have but
not not outside okay so like if you look
at if you look at the dynamic of that
area there's a huge Highway that goes
from Highway 70 that goes from Denver on
the Front Range up you know past all the
ski resorts into Vail into eagle and
then it kind of goes down through a big
the canyon Glenwood Canyon and kicks
back into to Aspen
that all the winter range there is split
by this massive Highway and then that
Highway has a an eight-foot game fence
along the whole whole thing and then you
know along that Veil Valley where
they're wanting to put put these or
where they are going to put these wolves
you know there's you know 50 000
full-time residents and you know there's
probably double that in the High season
ski season stuff unless you got these
huge ski resorts I guess what I'm
getting at is when somebody tells me
that the low-hanging fruit to kind of
rewild that areas is wolves it's just
[__] you know what I mean how is it
getting past though well it got passed
by a ballot initiative you know that the
ballot initiative is how wolves got you
know got to the situation they are now
and basically what the ballot initiative
did is it forced the CPW to take on this
goal of transplanting the the Wolves so
it wasn't the cpw's choice and they and
they you know there's a I don't know the
exact laws uh Joe but this the CPW and
that's the Colorado's Park the Colorado
Parks and Wildlife they're in charge of
managing the wildlife in Colorado how
can they put something like
the transplanting of wolves a very
complex
biological problem I mean it's you're
dealing with Biology and Wildlife how
can they put that as a ballot initiative
like how can they put that in the hands
of people other than
Wildlife Conservation experts Wildlife
biologists
well I mean the realities are laws our
laws allow that you know yeah but it
doesn't make rational sense no you know
but it's a it's a decision that for
people that are just like yeah that'd be
amazing let's put the Wolves out there
like people are gonna lose their dogs
like sure you're gonna your dogs are
gonna get eaten like it's going to
affect anyone who has livestock you're
gonna have a problem whether that
problems in three years or in five years
those problems are coming yeah dogs are
100 gonna get eaten right if you have
acute golden retriever like mine you
leave them outside like guess what that
dog's dead sure they're gonna team up on
that dog and tear it apart yeah and if
you're cool with going outside and
seeing wolves eat your dog like well
then you've made the right choice but if
you if you're not like if you don't
think they're going to go after
low-hanging fruit if you don't you don't
think they're going to go after easy
prey sure you don't understand wolves
talk to people that live in Alaska yeah
like you know anybody who lives in like
British Columbia like they have real
[__] wolf problems up there right and
these are of problems that we used to
have in the west but they eradicated
them right I mean I don't think it's
good to eradicate them I'm not saying
that what they did was right when they
poisoned horses and left dead horses
filled with strychnine and you know and
the Wolves all died off but
they did it for a [__] reason yeah
yeah what and that's the thing that's
that's so crazy about you know back to
the the process of how it happened
everybody who who wants wolves in
Colorado and we can get into you know
the depth they want them because that's
not really clear you know they they just
went through this whole uh you know
setting up the plan for the CPW and it
it became very clear in my mind watching
that process that they they don't really
want there to be any you know uh
management of wolves in Colorado either
it's gonna ever but no yeah so basically
well that's crazy yeah and so that that
week I think you know anybody rational
is going to be like look like we gotta
have like a top to the population
there's no management at all well so
here's the deal is they're not they have
a draft plan you know for to manage the
Wolves what happened is when the CPW did
that draft plan it included some
discussion of wolves being lethally
managed at all different stages you know
what I mean Joe like even now if they
you know a real problem with livestock
you know could they be lethally managed
but down the road once they had
once they had hit certain population
objectives could they be hunted right
like that was discussed well it turns
out the ballot initiative basically says
that wolves are a non-game species and
that was in the language of the ballot
initiative so they can't really they
can't really now say the CPW can't
really say that they're going to someday
be a hundred a hundred species in
Colorado I personally think and I you
know everything's like 2020 hindsight
but even when the ballot initiative
originally you know was out there and I
always thought it was going to pass by a
landslide that's what's so crazy because
it just barely passed but
um I always thought like the problem
with Colorado is it's different than
these other Western States you know
Idaho Montana Wyoming because they're
gonna They're Gonna Keep the population
in line through hunting or other you
know other methods but in Colorado I
don't think the politics are you know
Batman I think it's just going to be
like who knows what the top is on you
know how many there is how much they
affect the ungulate population you know
who who knows you know but what I was
going to say is what's crazy about this
ballot initiative and the Bummer part
about it is everybody that's going to
deal with the negative consequences
they're they're people that voted no in
but they're in the areas where the
wolves are going to be transplanted
everybody that voted for it they don't
have to deal with the downside they're
living in Boulder yeah dude and unlike
you man they're cool like I've been
around them in Canada they're way cool
but the the problem is is every person
that that I've interacted with in
British Columbia you know or even in the
western states that have a fair amount
of wolves every person is just trying to
make a living on a landscape you know
he's a guide an Outfitter a logger a
cattle ranch or whatever like he's out
there living He or she's out there
living with them and dealing with them
they're all just like when you ask about
wolves they're like it's just like you
know what I mean because they got to
deal with the negative consequences all
the time they're a totally different
kind of animal than any other animal
because they act as a pack and right
they have some sort of Intelligent
Communication they're they're badass
they're amazing yeah they're cunning and
crafty and they're efficient ruthless
Killers yeah and they also Surplus kill
you know I'm sure they find them like I
think it was Wyoming recently but they
found just like [__] giant pile of
elk that they yeah had trapped in high
snow and just tore to Pieces yeah yeah
and I don't know like the stats on how
common that is but you know other other
predators do that too yeah cats do that
yeah yeah but it's a bit you know the
difference between them is that they act
as a group yeah they're the only one of
those predators that acts as a large
group yeah no in in the in their their
effect I mean they're they're effective
I mean even when you talk to I know I
know uh a guy in British Columbia that's
I mean his whole world's his whole world
is focused on trapping them and I've sat
and talked to him just about like the
details you know like boiling and snares
you know how he goes in and puts his
snares in you know how he goes in and
checks them like all that bad little
snare sleep no sense yeah yeah yeah yeah
because they just pick up on that that
stuff you know they're just so smart
it's and they know that they're being
[__] with too oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah which it's funny because the first
thing you said is they're a dog and that
I mean you you have dogs you know how it
is like they get it figured out yeah
they know things yeah yeah for sure I
mean I talked to my dog like he
understands certain things right I'm
like come on dude let's go outside it
just starts going towards the door yeah
oh yeah
for sure I can I don't have to say it
like want to go outside yeah do you want
to go outside I can just say hey come on
man let's go outside yeah he's like oh
yeah let's go outside yeah are you
hungry and he's like [__] you I'm hungry
I'm like okay let's eat like he knows
what that means yeah he is he knows some
aspects of language sure and you know
what he is is like a really tame docile
version of a wolf yeah a wolf is like a
like have you ever been around a Belgian
Malinois yeah I I don't think I'm those
are the dogs they use in war and police
dogs okay they're [__] scary little
meat missiles I got you and they look at
you like this yeah they're always
thinking and you can't just keep one of
those [__] in your yard they're
too smart they're working dogs first of
all they climb fences yeah like a
chimpanzee they just go right up the
fence and over it I mean have you ever
seen like videos of Belgian Malinois
working I don't think I have Joe dude
I'm trying to put it's wild they can do
[__] where they leap through the air
like you can't [__] believe they
really can jump that high right like
soaring through the air I'm talking like
12 feet in the air they run jump off a
guy's back and then leap through the air
like climb over walls that are like 10
feet tall just by running up the wall
yeah it's it's insane that's that's a
wolf yeah this is a this is a Belgium oh
yeah I've seen it man look at this
I mean that's insane it is nuts how's
that dog doing that look at him running
up the [__] wall he's he's basically
a monkey got it figured out look he's
running up a [__] tree to get to him
it and then he's hanging on it crazy
man you know the diversity amongst dogs
is wild it is wild but these dogs in
particular are bred and look how smart
they are look you can walk across a type
robe look at that and then saying I mean
that's [__] insane dude they're so
intelligent but that's closer to a wolf
yeah way closer to look look at his ears
I mean they're they're basically an
athlete wolf yeah you know have you ever
seen these uh these Great Pyrenees dogs
that they run with the Sheep yes yeah
they're they're well they're cool in a
much different way yeah they basically
think they're sheep yeah you know pull
up a Great Pyrenees dogs yeah they're
interesting it's it's so wild that they
all came from wolves and you have so
many different styles of like the way
they look dude these dogs so so there's
big big domestic sheep permits where I
used to outfit so guys running you know
big bands of sheep periodically in the
wilderness areas and and they keep these
dogs with them and uh these dogs are
something else to run into you know in
the night up in the mountains or
whatever and they're they're just you
know they just protect those sheep just
you know you see these big bands of
sheep like this and
so do they keep wolves off of them yeah
so so I've heard mixed things in this
would be interesting because right where
they're going to put some of these
wolves in Colorado there's some pretty
big domestic sheep guys that run these
Pyrenees dogs oh Jesus and they actually
so
so sheep in the wilderness are one of
the few animals that are still guarded
by humans you know they usually have a
herder with them yeah and a lot of them
are guys from nowadays it seems to be
that most of them are from Peru I
believe and I used to run into the guys
because they've been out there living
with these Sheep Man for like weeks at a
time so yeah even though there's a
language barrier like when they see you
up there like they wanna they wanna hang
out you know say hi whatever just happy
to see people yeah they'll have like
they'll have a horse with them you know
maybe I don't know probably five six
hundred cheap and they'll have a couple
of those dogs wow you know but back to
your original question is I've heard
mixed things about these dogs ability to
to deal with Wolves you know and and it
has to do with the fact that well
there's more than you know there's a
group of wolves so if they can draw one
of these dogs off you know that wolves
can wolves can kill them